infer is a tool that tries to find bugs
in computer code
and it does this it's called a static
program
analyzer it does this without running
the program so it takes the program in
as input
then it examines the program and it
tries to reason about the program
in something like how a human would do
it and as it's doing this
it makes guesses about the program and
sometimes the guesses are oh there will
be a bug there will be
a null point or crash there will be a
race condition
amongst concurrent threads things like
this so once it finds potential bugs
it tells the facebook developers and
they get to act upon them also
it's an open source tool so it's used by
other companies try to find
um as many bugs as we can to prevent
them from getting into production
we've done one or two videos on touring
and undecidability on all these sort of
issues with paradox etc has this been
done with machine learning or something
can you talk to me about that
it's done with um some techniques in the
older kind of ai called symbolic ai
and so our tools have two techniques
in them um that are ai related one is
called the frame problem
which is about describing what the
what the program can do without listing
all of the myriad of things that it
can't do
and then the other problem is called
abductive inference which is
something from the philosophy of science
by the philosopher charles pierce this
is about
making hypotheses usually it's about
making scientific hypotheses
but our tools make guesses about the
computer program the guess might be
this bit of code needs an acyclic linked
list
in order to run without producing a
crash
so we our tool would look at the code
and make that guess
and then try to confirm that guess so
it's so this is how a human might do it
a human might look at a code
see a while loop and then hypothesize oh
i betcha
this needs an acyclic linked list or
it's a click linked list
and so the tool tries to make these
kinds of guesses
and it does it using symbolic logic
using a form of symbolic logic called
separation logic
and it makes the guesses then it tries
to confirm the guesses
as i understand it the the key to what
turing said was that it was in general
you couldn't do this
so turing showed that in general a
certain problem the halting problem
can't be solved
by a computer algorithms and it follows
that many other problems something
called rises
theorem it follows that many other
problems can't be solved
by an algorithm but can be solved means
for all input programs
can we answer in a perfect yes no way
whether say
the program might crash the program has
a race condition
the program has a security violation so
there's two parameters here
for all input programs and perfect yes
no
so if you relax the for all input
programs and look at a smaller
collection of programs
then there's something you can do and
then the other way you can play is you
can relax the perfect yes no
answers and so our tools do both of
those
so we're concentrating on the programs
that humans write at facebook
which is a small small small subset of
all programs so we don't have to work
for all input programs
and then the other thing that we do is
the perfect yes no answers are still
very difficult
so there's something about computability
theory which says
when you've got an undecidable problem
you need to approximate it
so you can get bigger and bigger subsets
of the undecidable problem
or bigger and bigger subsets of the of
the no part of the undecidable problem
but you will never get the perfect
answer so you have to approximate
and so this is an interesting thing
about this is this this means
you know that you'll never be finished
you'll never find the algorithm do do
with perfect yes no answers
but what we do is we train our our
techniques
on the facebook code basis and then we
listen to what the programmers
say and to what production crashes say
to try to make these approximations
better so we are working on
formally undecidable problems but we're
trying to
approximate them and they're we're using
what the facebook engineers
and what the production statistics tell
us they guide us towards good
approximations
so that's what's quite fascinating to me
when i was an academic before
and i thought oh um undecidable problems
this is a show stopper you shouldn't try
to
answer these problems but as soon as you
get in the game
you realize oh what i need to do is
approximate
then you're in a better position there's
a whole computer science theory called
abstract interpretation
about this approximation this is a bit
like kind of the computer version if you
can't please all of the people all the
time right
well yeah especially i mean it's all of
the people we would like to be able to
because again
um all of the people aren't still aren't
going to write those infinitely many
programs
right but it's impossible at the moment
to make one of these tools to tackle an
undecidable problem
that works for all input code bases in
the world
um it's not possible but what we've
found is that we can train them for
certain specific kinds of code bases
and a good place to do this is an
industry like facebook has
various code bases very big um hundreds
of millions of lines of code
but there is some regularity to that
code and there are design principles
that the the engineers use
so we try to get to know the mind of the
engineers
get to know the mind of the programmers
and we can just know that by feedback
from them we don't just dream up what it
is
and we tailor our algorithms to that and
then we start getting good results
but if we try to just apply to all
random code in the world
then we don't get good results and i
think that's true in general for the
area
you've got these titans of computer
science as you mentioned you know
touring and
various other people kind of working on
this problem but where do you come in
i come in in the early 2000s i was part
of a i had a research team
and and i was um working on a theory
called separation logic which i
developed with my colleague professor
john reynolds
from carnegie mellon this built on
another
another of the things that touring did
so touring did all of the bit about
undecidability but he also founded the
area of program verification
he wrote a paper in i think 1949 called
checking a large routine
for him large was a few tens of lines of
code he showed how the human
could write little logical statements
around various parts of the code
and then confirm that the code did the
right thing we made a theory to try to
do similar sorts of stuff
for more modern software with the
pointers and the objects and things that
one finds in modern software
and this worked very very well for
proving programs by hand like touring
was doing we scaled his
techniques so we could do better and
then i had um
some a graduate student cristiano
calcanya who said
maybe we can convert this into a tool
that tries to do the same thing
and then cristiano and a number of other
people joined me and we did years of
research
and then him and another fellow
destefano they decided
let's make a startup company and try to
make this real and facebook bought the
startup company in 2013
a company called mnodix and then presto
i ended up at facebook so i started from
proving programs by hand like touring
was doing this is like
take this infinite collection of input
programs let's make it one program
right now we can get a perfect yes no
answer but the human has to guide it
then we made very efficient techniques
for the human to do the proof
using separation logic then we said
let's make the computer mimic what we're
doing in our hand proofs
and so we did that and oddly enough it
all worked out and
i never never never expected to be able
to run these algorithms on tens of
millions of lines of code
never but there are some technical
reasons why it worked but we made it
there
so i didn't plan to apply these
techniques to tens of millions lines of
code
but it happened we've done a number of
videos on things like uh functional
programming and i know there's a lot of
talk about
um using functional programs to prove
things to do with programs
will this work on any kind of say
programming language and things or are
you
set on whatever code base facebook is
using see
it works on any kind of programming
language and
there is a school of thought which says
we need to change the programming
language to make it easier to verify
but i come from a different point of
view i say there's
billions of lines of code out there and
instead of rewriting the world
what mathematical logic is very powerful
why don't we try
to deal with that code as is and this
theory separation logic when we
discovered it
we were shocked because we were able to
give nice
mathematical pretty proofs for not only
c programs but assembly language
programs
and this was a shock because my
prejudice at the time and my
co-author john reynolds prejudice was
thou shalt use functional programming
languages
or lovely things like that but then i
found that certain very dirty algorithms
had beautiful proofs like there's a an
algorithm
for coding doubly linked lists where
instead of having
having forward and back pointers use the
xor of them
in order to um use less memory
and this is it's a funny program but
one day john reynolds said to me peter
tell me the dirtiest program you know
i told him this program and then the
next morning
he came into the office and said it's
not a dirty program anymore here's the
proof
this was really a shock and an eye
opener and so as a result
i i feel like yes programming languages
are important and programming language
design is so important but
using mathematical logic there's no
reason why we can't attack all of the
code
if a programmer wants to dispose
all of the nodes in a tree to delete
them they can write a recursive
procedure
that works like this if i if i
you mentioned it's open source we have a
lot of coders who watch the the videos
here if somebody wants to go and have a
look at it or have a try over a play of
it
how'd they go about that where would
they go yeah there's they can go to our
website called
it's fbiinfer.com they can go to our
website
but um once they're there they can
download infer from github
um they can run it on their own code
they can search for integrations with
whatever build system they
might be using we use a build system
called buck there's another build system
called
gradle which people use there's various
build systems
so they can do that they can get
community support and maybe ask a few
questions
is the next step for it to then start
fixing the code for them
that's very interesting so um that's a
dream and there is a
a project at facebook not by my team but
by another team which
you does automatically fix some of
infers
warnings simpler ones no pointer
exceptions
um now that's that's pretty remarkable
um it doesn't automatically fix it
automatically suggest it suggests a fix
but we're letting the human decide so
the humans are the final
they have the final say whether to
accept that fix or not
so that's really exciting but i don't
try to
i don't tend to think that the robots
are going to fix all of our code for us
because for any given bug
often there's more than there's no
unique cause and there's no unique
fix and at this moment and for the first
sealable future
human judgment is needed especially on
the more subtle ones to know which of
the fixes
is is the right one and right
i think a a reasonable approach is to
have a tool suggest several fixes
and then the humans to decide but i'm
not in the camp of thinking that the
the bots are going to give us the right
fixes
i don't think it's really possible in
the foreseeable future
development is a process have you had
anything where
it's gone wrong at all have you had
problems with it at all
now we're in the realm of software
engineering we're not in the realm of
mathematical logic
so it's it can't be perfect you can't be
perfect um
here's one example one example oh so we
have false positives
where we give wrong answers but there
are more comical things that we've gone
wrong
one time um infer ran wild
and and it spammed one of the developers
so
it found a potential error or what i
thought was a potential error
and instead of re reporting it once it
reported it 60 times
and luckily the developer that did it to
did not get upset he just laughed
and he sent us a message saying is infer
gone a little bit insane today
there's a very interesting slogan at
facebook called move fast and break
things there's an old slogan if we were
to break things with the infer tool so
say we spammed the developer by giving
them 60 copies of the same bug report
which might not be the best thing if we
did this to all the developers so if we
make a mistake
and it's on honest mistake and then we
move fast to resolve it
to help the people then it's good
so i gave you a comical instance of
where infer
went wrong but on any given day infer
will make
bug report suggestions which are not
true and
it will miss potential bugs too and this
is all related to the undecidability
right
the undecidability of the problems we're
working on the undecidability in the
sense of touring and girdle
you're going to run into these problems
if you've got an undecidable
if you're working on undecidable things
so
yeah it's another another way to say it
is because it's imperfect because of
undecidability
but it also means we'll never be
finished
so our job will never be finished it's
like a job for life
working on an undecidable problem we're
contributing
some funds to help support bletchley
park there's the link to touring
which is um one of my intellectual
heroes but
also um bletchley park historically was
important
in computing and in society for the role
that it played in in the second world
war
parallel way of removing all the nodes
in the tree